Vice President Biden may want to avoid
the impeachment trial but he's not
backing away from his feud with Bernie
Sanders and O'Keefe caught up with him
in Des Moines and they had how do we
describe this IDI his remarkable
exchange of good word that's one way of
putting it Gail look we wanted to ask
the former vice president why he's
feuding again with Bernie Sanders
remember earlier this week Biden told us
that he accepted Sanders apology after
one of his supporters called the former
vice president corrupt but within hours
both camps were out with duelling attack
videos Biden calling out quote Bernie's
negative attacks and Sanders raising
questions about Biden's previous
willingness to fiddle with federal
benefits while Sanders is in Washington
dealing with impeachment Biden was out
here talking to voters so we wanted to
ask him why this change in strategy
take a look yesterday you said you
accepted Bernie's apology now you're
attacking him why are you doing that why
wasn't his apology enough mr. vice
president why it's why you're getting
nervous man calm down it's okay he
apologized for saying that I was corrupt
he didn't say anything about whether or
not I was and I wasn't sure where that
was going what were you thinking yes
yeah look we asked the candidates
questions how they respond is up to them
and clearly in this case Biden a little
touchy because he's sensitive to this
charge that he wants to change up social
security yes as a senator in the 1990s
he was open to making changes to federal
benefits to balance the budget but now
as a presidential candidate he says he
wants to preserve and expand Social
Security in part because seniors are
living longer how exactly it would be
paid for as a detail to be sorted out
later but look with Biden and Sanders
either tied or first and second here in
Iowa and across the country this is a
feud that's likely to continue with 11
days until the Iowa caucus and ever the
stakes are high
on behalf of the supremely combat
O'Keefe I counted only two wise from you
and I counted three but but well at
first it seemed he didn't want to answer
it but he thought about it he turned
around he wanted to address it so I give
him credit for that
alright don't get anxious yeah